and here we
go
hello everybody i'm jeff keely and this
is summer game fest a live showcase of
what's next in the wide wide world of
video games we are live here in los
angeles and whether you're streaming
from home or watching inside an imax
theater welcome to our showcase event
over the next few hours we'll give you
updates on the games you love be joined
by special developer guests and yes have
a few surprises along the way too now
what i love about this show is that it's
a true cross industry showcase whether
you play on xbox pc playstation switch
or mobile we'll have games for you it
doesn't matter your platform of choice
we're all here to come together as one
community that simply loves the art of
amazing video games the biggest
franchises in the industry are here like
call of duty you'll get introduced to
exciting new worlds and new teams and
will make room for small independent
developers who we think deserve the
spotlight too if we do this right
hopefully you'll discover a few new
games to put on your wish list
and even if you don't get every
announcement you desire let's face it
you're not gonna get everything today
but we've got a lot of great stuff so
let's get started
over 30 years ago capcom street fighter
hit arcades and ever since this
legendary japanese fighting game series
has continued to evolve street fighter 6
is coming in 2023 and right now we're
excited to officially confirm a
character coming to the game and show
you the exclusive first gameplay footage
enjoy
[Music]
you will know what hit you
let me have some fun
let's get this mission started
got you in my sights
[Music]
time to end this
i'm just on another level
[Music]
it's all about the comb all right next
it's time for a brand new game
announcement here at summer game fest
check this out
[Music]
sergeant leo alvarez of the cm left
recon squad
our mission was to enter the tantalus
space locate the comsat relay and bring
it back online
we found the relay
but there was a
problem
get that door closed now private
take the lead
oh
this ain't good
what we found
was a new kind of evil
and it found us first
this
wasn't human
retreat
open fire
hold that door sergeant
i don't know what i saw in there
i know when i close my eyes
i still see it
now everyone's dead
and someone needs to know
that was aliens dark descent and it's
coming in 2023 to console and pc
next two years ago at the game awards we
revealed the callisto protocol from the
creative forces behind the dead space
franchise today i am thrilled to get to
show you the first raw game play
alongside its creator glenn schofield
but first here's the quote-unquote
scofield cut of the brand new trailer
with a little more gore
[Music]
take a look outside
did you know that they call callisto the
dead moon
dead
just like you would have been if i
hadn't fished you out of that wreck
so whatever you're holding on to right
there
that's your old life
you gotta let that go
because
your new
life
is entirely
in my hands
i'm just trying to give you a chance
at rebirth
[Music]
uh
i just love that last part
gives me chills every time
[Applause]
welcome
to your new home
[Music]
that's right we know what you wanted to
see and joining me now glenn scofield
striking distance glenn uh first of all
congratulations this game looks
absolutely incredible and i gotta say
the fact that you have built this team
this studio new ip shipping this
december all in covid blows me away so
congratulations yeah thanks man uh
thanks for having us i really do
appreciate it jeff um and you know for a
second just give me a second
you know i want to thank you uh for all
you've done for the game industry uh all
these years man i i think i've known you
like 16 17 years now and uh
um you've been an ambassador
um you've amplified new games new
studios and uh i just wanted to thank
you i really do appreciate it thank you
it's not about me it's about you guys
yeah i know i appreciate that thank you
so much and yeah it's so fun to do these
shows and to show this game so people
saw the trailer but what i'm so excited
today is that you just brought a raw
gameplay sequence this game is in
development and people are gonna be
blown away i think when they see it but
tell us a bit about what are we gonna
see today yeah we got a couple minutes
of uh like you said like we're all game
play um it's two segments in the first
half of the game uh one is the med bay
another one is the power station and
you're gonna see uh some
new enemies some brutality some uh just
about everything we we're showcasing a
new uh weapon called the grip it's a
like a gravity gun but it picks up the
enemies and it shoves them into giant
fans it rips them apart it's great and
uh and then check out the uh
the nice ending we have where we uh you
know we usually will kill our main
character jacob and in a very unique way
and uh
uh just for a second i i want to thank
the team man like you said through covid
through everything else the dedication
the hard work uh you guys are amazing
thank you very much oh well glenn i
gotta say again you know what you guys
are shipping this year this looks like a
world-class next-gen game uh it's it's
rare that teams are bringing something
out like this this year and
let's let the footage speak for itself
schofield striking distance here it is
the first gameplay of the callisto
protocol
[Music]
what's going on
uh
[Music]
foreign
so
oh
oh my god
that just happened all right moving on
this october call of duty modern warfare
2 arrived infinity ward is once again
returning to its roots for a modern day
action game and today we're about to
show you the world premiere of its
gameplay with a level play through to
tell us more let's head to the port of
long beach to check in with johanna
ferris the head of call of duty
[Music]
hi everyone in 2019 modern warfare
changed everything and on october 28th
we usher in a new era of call of duty
with the launch of modern warfare 2.
we are back we are bigger and we are
bringing the entire team
price
gaz soap alejandro and of course ghost
we needed a stage big enough to debut
call of duty in a whole new way
inspired by the world we're about to
enter
oil rigs cargo ships and staggering odds
are just the beginning
here is modern warfare 2.
[Music]
ship is
actual reset
copy get to work
up
all shadows was on this platform
i want full containment
cut right clear through
ah
room clear coming out
channel one moving to the southeastern
12.
[__] door
we're moving to the main deck what's
your status boarding the ship with
shadow three now roger
[Applause]
[Music]
we gotta roll
off
come on
move to the halifax
[Music]
[Applause]
clear
[Music]
open
on that damn ship
actually we got a problem
you have your orders son stop that
launch
let's go
scare those controls stop this vessel
yeah how do we forge
take the ramp
all night
let's have ourselves a gunfight
missile controls are on the bridge
have to stop the lawn
copy that
[Music]
reloading
between them
check your corner
this one
all right stand back
shadow one going explosive on bridget
three two one execute
[Music]
pre-order now and get early access to
the open beta
that's what we're talking about and
joining us now up from long beach
johanna great to see you how's
everything it's great thanks uh great to
have you with us and also jeff from uh
infinity ward so
we saw the first game play thanks for
that extended sequence looks incredible
uh jeff tell us a bit about that mission
uh where is that set in the game what
are we seeing there absolutely so um
first of all we're really excited to
welcome back uh captain john price and
uh
uh gaz uh garrick um
you know they're not they're not
actually in what we just saw today but
uh they're returning members from 141
and then the other two characters uh
that were you may recognize from the
older franchise that we're reimagining
are uh simon ghost riley and uh of
course uh soap john mctavish um and then
a couple other new characters in here
that we're really excited uh that we got
to uh create for this game um
first uh commander philip graves and uh
mexican special forces uh colonel
alejandro and alejandro i gotta say
we're it's a character we're really
excited about he's a guy who's super
capable and a guy who's just as
important as test course 141. um but as
far as the level is concerned um you
know this i got a shout out to iw you
know this was a tremendous collaboration
across all of the the different uh
disciplines as you saw everybody coming
together some really uh motivated devs
here and uh you know you saw the the
wind and the uh animations and the
awesome sound design and of course our
new water tech which is actually pushing
the boat in different directions it's
creating a physically dynamic
environment allowing for the cover you
were seeing in certain cases you could
be behind cover and then suddenly that
cover would shift and leave you exposed
but it also leaves the enemy exposed
creating this emergent gameplay um so
again i'm i'm very excited just can't
wait that i'm so excited that we get to
show it off today and that's just a hint
of where things are going to go uh john
tell us a bit about call of duty overall
modern warfare 2 obviously you know
we're so excited that it's back this
year but you've got lots going on across
holiday what can we expect from you guys
this year yeah we um first of all thanks
for having us here we're just so excited
for october 28th
it's such a big moment not just for
modern warfare 2 and everything that
jeff and the team at infinity ward have
built but it really marks the step
change what we're calling a
transformational moment for the entire
franchise you're going to see
incredible rendering incredible graphics
all the things just within the game
itself built all on one shared engine
now
across war zone and modern warfare 2
going forward of course there's a lot of
chatter and interest about the new war
zone experience we're affectionately
calling it war zone 2.0
there will be
a stand-alone experience of war zone for
current existing
players as well so we're going to sort
of feed the entire community there but
all eyes on the 28th
and again i think the collaboration's
just been incredible everybody's so
excited for task force one for one um
warzone coming to mobile as well for
players on the go
we're on steam as you know i mean so
it's just a big moment and there's going
to be a lot more to come in the in the
months to follow well before we we leave
we got to ask a little bit about war
zone 2. i know we just you know we're
showing gameplay here on this but can
you tell us anything there's a little it
seems like there's a little bit of a
tease maybe in the trailer yesterday
yeah when we're seeing that from the
community we love when the fans can pick
up some things um some chatter about
maybe seeing high-rise and other
elements but we will get into the
details of war zone 2.0 for sure it will
be an extension of the modern warfare 2
universe so all the more reason why we
think this game this moment is is such
an important uh title for all of us
looking looking ahead and like we said
we're having a bold vision around the
entire future for the franchise so we're
in we're in position we're really
excited all right well we're looking
forward to october thanks so much for
giving us a first look at the gameplay
call of duty modern warfare 2. thanks
johanna and jeff um all right well we've
got lots more summer game fest still to
go and now it's time to announce a
classic pc gaming franchise is coming
back with a sequel over 30 years after
its first release i love this game when
i was growing up so i'm honored to share
this very first look
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's turn back time back in
2017 we announced witchfire at the game
awards almost five years later i am so
excited the team at the astronauts in
poland has put together an in-depth look
at the gameplay of this dark fantasy
first person shooter which will enter
early access soon i am so excited to
play this and i bet you will be too
after you see this
[Music]
okay next up comes an ambitious new game
from a new independent studio in europe
starring some very familiar names enjoy
this world premiere new game
announcement
[Music]
officer taylor medlog
today um
i can't believe what i saw
solace
everything okay in there
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
something's going on here
and i need to find out what it is
[Music]
that's something brand new and look who
it is
troy and roger in person guys uh this is
so fun the fact that you're working on a
game together what a cool team up uh
welcome to the show uh good to be here i
gotta ask you guys uh who are your
characters in this game
well i get to play a character named
wyatt taylor as a medical officer who's
stationed at this uh base fort solace
and uh it's the epicenter of this
mystery that we'll discover and uncover
as we go through the game and of course
my character will be at times in
opposition with
roger's character
the battle we've been waiting to see
every once in a while yeah yeah oh man
we can't wait to show you what we've
been working on and by the way jeff this
looks awesome man it's so great to be
here thanks for having us it's so great
that you're in another game we i mean
it's feeling like this is your first
game since you read deadpool one of the
first major ones for a while and i play
a character by the name of jack leary
he's a maintenance engineer on a remote
martian mining post
his job is to make sure that none of the
equipment breaks down while it's on
their graveyard shift the graveyard
shift meaning mars and earth are really
far apart from each other and their
orbits around the sun so help is not a
simple call away
uh i gotta ask i think a lot of people
will see this thing and they'll probably
wonder you know it's a new team right uh
you know independent studio in europe
that's making this but with huge
production values i'm curious like how
did you guys get attached to this tell
us a bit about the background i i will
say that 2020 to me was the most
impactful year for games it was the
first i mean obviously we had this
unprecedented event with the pandemic
and that forced the way that we looked
at everything as a society but also the
way this industry functioned it was also
brand new consoles we had more tools
that were being made available that were
leveling the playing field between like
the aaa studios and the indie studios of
the triple i studios and so just like
anybody else we got reached out uh james
tinsdale with this brand new studio said
we'd like for you to
consider being a part of this game and
he walked me through a very brief
description of what the experience was
going to be like and
in the very beginning he said
it's we want this to feel it's a it's a
tight thriller we want it to feel like
dead space meets uh duncan jones moon
and i was like sign me up i'm into that
absolutely and full like performance
capture and everything yeah absolutely
new studio brand new energy and of
course
i get to work with one of the best of
the business and me i get the privilege
who's the other getting to see this guy
and watch him in action i know i love to
work and i love the challenges and all
the new innovations that this medium
provides to performers we can't wait to
show you what we've been working on i
think it's going to knock you out i
guess i've seen some of the behind the
scenes and the performance capture on
real engine 5 i mean this is it looks
absolutely phenomenal can you give us a
hint about the the game play like what
are we going to do in this game yeah the
verbs are always important so we're
going to let the game speak for itself
we'll be showing you more later on but
uh this is a game where you as the
player you're going to be exploring
we're going to be discovering like we
said it's a very tight thriller so
you're moving very fast pace through
this world you'll be multiple locations
multiple ways for you to traverse which
we're excited to show you about uh and
then the the narrative is a huge element
to this the they they didn't waste any
any resources on the the performance for
sure i gotta tell one quick story if i
can um that was one of our favorite
moments um
there is a lot of action in this game
and that was at the the forefront of
this
and to speak to the performance capture
aspect we brought in an incredible i
gotta give him a shout out to nathaniel
our stunt coordinator who walked us
through and really approached this in a
completely different way than anything
i've ever done before he says i want to
know the story of this fight and so
roger and i sat down we said these are
where our characters are and he goes
give me one hour and i will come back to
you with the story of this fight and
after an hour he comes to us and he goes
it was like a like a recovery program it
was 12 steps and he walked us through
this incredible fight and i about
halfway out halfway through i started
tuning him out and i was like hey man i
just want you know i've got no ego about
this but i can do a lot of things but i
i can't do this and he grabbed me by my
shoulders and he says oh you can you
will and it's going to be glorious and
we did and we did a dance it was a lot
of trust and it worked out yeah i mean
we're excited
yeah i mean this is so cool to see is it
an independent studio doing this teaming
up with you guys we can't wait to see
more troy roger thanks for joining us
here happy to be here thank you all
right appreciate very much guys all
right well next up keeping up with the
space theme it's time to world premiere
a very exciting new game which will
feature a musical score by industry
legend mick gordon this one is gonna
grab you and we are so honored to debut
it
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
doesn't that look great that was routine
coming to xbox and pc it was first
announced a decade ago and is now
officially back i can't wait to see more
now it's time to check in with a very
special guest who's been in his fair
share of video games including most
recently fortnite as the foundation
dwayne johnson
welcome to summer game fest how are you
what's up everybody and what's up jeff
and what is up to the
summer game fest audiences live
streaming right now around the world and
everybody inside the epic imax theaters
dwayne johnson here coming at you from
my iron paradise the very hot
and sweaty
and smelly iron paradise uh powered by
of course zoa energy the number one
fastest growing energy drink in the game
you guys know me uh by a lot of
nicknames the rock
la roca in spanish
uncle handsome sexiest man alive
big drink energy
always room for a cheesy joke there's
always room for the extra-large cheese
pizza especially when i'm delivering and
i deliver them often uh you guys also
know me as the
greatest and most electrifying surprise
in gaming that happened you know me as
the foundation
and i got to tell you guys number one
thank you so much for the crazy response
of me becoming the foundation but also
i gotta say that you know i've had such
a pleasure uh working with um epic games
and uh the teams over there and we
cannot wait to show you what we have in
store for the future and speaking of the
future in the future you will also know
me as black adam
black adam as millions of you know
around the world who know the black out
of mythology he is ruthless he is
unstoppable and for those who don't i
always like to say a quick tutorial is
this
um black adam has the powers of superman
but the only difference well there's a
few differences but one of the biggest
differences is superman's weakness is
magic and black adam's one of his
superpowers is magic so you do the math
uh october 21st i cannot wait for you
guys to see black adam around the world
in theaters only and you guys will
finally see the hierarchy of power in
the dc universe change uh it has been an
honor to become black adam and it was a
it is a role that's in my dna and that i
was born to play i was born to play the
man in black and i'm honored to show it
to you guys on october 21st so until
then uh
stay healthy stay safe
stay focused
keep having fun keep kicking ass uh
enjoy your gaming and i'll see you down
the road
this is black adam
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i was a slave until i died
then i was reborn a god
now
i kneel before no one
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
behind you
did you just catch a rocket
you know my fresco
[Music]
one two three
so
[Music]
oh
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
mix it
[Music]
do what it takes
i'm so fresh
mix it all up
[Music]
that was so fun to see courage and ray
and that fall guys piece and you can
play and download fall guys for free
starting june 21st across all platforms
including nintendo switch xbox pc and
playstation
all right back to another new game
announcement we're going to announce a
brand new game and universe from a new
team of legendary developers check this
out
[Music]
signals breaking up command i'll do one
last scan see you soon over
okay hurry
[Music]
command i
may be on to something
[Music]
i have it command repeat i have it
mission accomplished
hang tight doc i've got this
[Music]
[Applause]
glad you could make it we gotta move
now
there's a storm coming
and hell's coming with it
there you have it tim congratulations
stormgate is real we have a name and
some details uh so first of all
congratulations on this announcement
we're so excited about the return of rts
brand new uh franchise what is a
stormgate though all right so stormgates
are portals that open during a massive
solar storm that unleash the infernal
host on future earth
okay uh and we saw some hints of some i
mean you know you guys coming from
blizzard and starcraft everyone wants to
know about races uh you know tell us
about the sides in this rts game yeah
we're unveiling our first two factions
today but there will be more so the
human resistance and we saw an
archaeologist from the human resistance
in that
intro cinematic uh and then also the
infernal hosts who are these demon-like
monsters who come from another world
i think one thing everyone wants to know
about especially your background
pedigree of the team of you know where
do you want to push the rts genre it's
something we've all loved for decades
but you know opportunity for a lot of
innovation
i know you're going to show us i think
some some hints of where you're going to
go image-wise with the actual gameplay
made in unreal engine but any sense of
what you want to do for the game play in
this game
absolutely i but the first thing i want
to say is we are very consciously trying
to stay true to what players already
love about rts um
where we're really trying to push the
genre and be innovative first off
approachability
for one thing we're free to play
but no pay to win no nfts nothing like
that just to
lower that barrier to entry to get
players in but we're also really trying
to be a lot more social so you'll be
able to play the campaign cooperatively
we've got three player open-ended co-op
and we've even got three versus three
for competitive multiplayer but of
course we've also still got one v1
competitive and as a little surprise i
think we've got some first kind of work
in progress images from the game right
yeah these are still very much still uh
being worked on but some shots of uh
actual assets that we're building in
unreal engine five
wow well i i love it 2023 you said for
the betas people can sign up now get
ready and i'm just so thrilled that
there is a a brand new rts franchise
coming from you guys and your background
and what you did you know blizzard and
starcraft we're so excited about this
team frost giant uh thank you so much
for giving us your announcement today on
summer game fast thank you so much for
having us here really grateful awesome
all right frost giant stormgate keep an
eye out for it now it's time for another
indie game announcement that i'm excited
to share with you high water check this
one out
good morning high water dwellers high
water pirate radio keeping you in the
know with our flow
alphaville authorities continue to deny
false rumors that alphaville elites are
planning to evacuate to mars true or not
the one thing we can't deny is that the
world ended on a sunny day
[Music]
the wave was coming but the sky was
clear i let it wash over
[Music]
the world ended on a sunny day
boys and girls surfing
[Music]
what a breathtaking trailer high water
is an adventure strategy game set in a
world ravaged by extreme climate change
now speaking of the world around us the
conflict in ukraine is not far from
anyone's mind and it's impacted the
development of games including replaced
from sad cat studios a belarusian studio
with devs from belarus and ukraine the
team had long hoped to reveal a new
trailer here today but were
understandably unable to complete it in
time guys i just want to say we're
thinking of you and all the developers
impacted by the conflict and hope to be
able to share your work at a future show
all right our next game is an official
selection of the tribeca games festival
it's american arcadia where you play
trevor whose life is being televised
with the viewing population constantly
voting you up or down when you become
unpopular you need to start running for
your life
check this out
picture a city where technology and
science go hand in hand with fun and
entertainment
my grandfather elijah walton had a dream
to build the city of tomorrow that dream
is now a reality and that city is
arcadia
a 43 square mile metropolis where each
and every citizen enjoys a life of
luxury and comfort
broadcast live 24 hours a day seven days
a week on every digital platform
american arcadia
control
subject on the run on camera four zero
two five interrupt broadcast immediately
listen to me we can't allow trevor hills
to escape under any circumstances
trevor
trevor can you hear me
be careful and don't make a sound
[Applause]
don't worry
i'm going to get you out of there
now last year marvel and 2k announced
marvel's midnight sons a tactical rpg
from firaxis games the studio behind
x-com and civilizations heroes from the
avengers and x-men cross over with
supernatural ones like blade and ghost
rider for a battle against lilith the
mother of demons today we've got a look
at some new folks set to join the battle
[Music]
this world has no hope under your watch
surrender your pain with me
and i will make you whole once more
there there
[Music]
typical parker luck
i'm gonna need some backup
[Music]
so
master of puppies
[Music]
my name is
counting on you again old friend
three
two
one
that used to always work well it did
that one time
that was midnight suns and now we're
moving on to the wonderful world of
cuphead the delicious last course and
can you believe it we're only a couple
weeks away from playing the delicious
last course dlc you see how they did
that for cuphead joining me now is maya
maldenhauer from studio mdhr so first of
all maya it's really coming it's really
coming june 30th on all major platforms
we are thrilled well i'm so thrilled too
that uh i think all the fans can't
believe that this is here and i've been
lucky enough to play this actually on my
steam deck uh last week you guys gave me
a copy this
i can't people are not going to be ready
for how amazing this looks and the
backgrounds and what you guys have done
i feel like you've you've amped up
obviously the gameplay it's difficult as
we would expect but the visual look you
guys have taken it even to the next
level i didn't think it was possible
yeah we absolutely did i couldn't
pinpoint one thing that we're proud of
in this because we really honed our
craft took everything to the next level
from animation the backgrounds the music
gameplay design um and of course a new
playable character miss chalice i'm very
proud of her
chalice is fun to play as and even
though this is a dlc it feels like it's
its own game inside of cuphead in many
ways it is it is definitely yeah you
just get on the island and there you are
off to this new uh new territory which
is yeah it's our biggest island yet
super-sized bosses lots of secrets to
discover um don't let any rock go
unturned
yes and lots of challenge ahead well i
know you brought i i know you want you
don't want people to necessarily have
too much spoiled about the game but you
brought a little something a little
something yeah it's a brand new gameplay
footage of one of our new bosses
mortimer freeze it takes place in an icy
arena
and features some of my personal
favorite attacks and transformations we
hope everyone enjoys it all right let's
check it out cuphead the delicious last
course next wild
[Music]
so
look at us
[Music]
now if you want even more cuphead and
who doesn't tomorrow we will show you an
exclusive look at season two of the
cuphead show when i co-host netflix's
geeked week which will include new show
and game announcements it streams at 10
a.m pacific 1 p.m eastern
and that's not all there's more summer
game fest all weekend long coming up
next is the day of the devs indie
showcase with i am 8bit and double fine
then devolvers marketing countdown to
marketing tomorrow after geeked week
there is the epic game store showcase at
11 a.m pacific 2 p.m eastern with news
on rocket league and the tribeca game
showcase and sunday don't miss the xbox
and bethesda game showcase with a look
at the future of xbox and game pass
now we have some exciting news for
nintendo switch and pc fans about neon
white a game where you play an assassin
from hell who slays demons for the
chance to ascend to heaven
[Music]
we're called neons
sinners plucked from hell to do god's
dirty work
but i'm finding it hard to believe we're
in heaven
ten days here new day new mission from
think you can win me over by showering
me with gifts uh
[Music]
we've shown you lots of games today made
by huge teams now it's time for a game
made by a single father in poland
over the past year he's brought on some
help to bring his vision for a
fast-paced action game midnight fight
express to life let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
you know the saying get knocked down get
up again that whole spiel
well it's time partner
time to rise up
together
it's happening the big guy's actually
going through with it while i sat at his
side surprised his dollar signs
had the stink of corruption all over me
you know who put it there
not not him
me
will i ain't wearing it anymore and
neither are you
tonight we wash this whole damn city
down
[Music]
such a cool game and i'm happy to
announce that a pc demo of this game is
going live right now on steam and will
be part of the steam next fest next week
i really want more playable games to get
in the hands of you guys at home and
that's one of them check it out all
right joining me now is megan from
digital extremes to talk all things
warframe megan how you doing i'm so good
my fellow canadians i know we got like
we just happen to always have these
canadian teams on the show i don't know
how that works out right okay we do well
we have a great connection we've also
done a lot with warframe over the years
and i know right now anyone watching on
twitch for more than 30 minutes this
show is going to get a special twitch
drop right that's right i already have
seen people getting it so it's very
exciting she's right there loud and
proud protea 30 minutes for watching
thank you for letting us kind of take
over
your special events category but she is
there and she is for you if you are
properly linked up no warframe you know
i said we've done a lot over the years
you guys have done incredible things
with the game and i know you have
tennocon coming up in july which is your
big kind of event of the year to reveal
what's next what what can you tell us
well i can't tell too much
but yeah july 16 2022 it's a digital
event again this year
today actually we just launched the
digital items for it so you can get some
in-game goodies some really cool
cosmetics some merch all that really
great stuff went live today but of
course the reason i'm here
is to you know kind of debut we have our
tenno live during tennocon which is our
big reveal of the night and we usually
do is a little bit of a gameplay a
little bit of a demo and i think a lot
of people can suspect what it might be
but i'm here to kind of confirm what it
is that tunnel live is going to show
and what is that
can i say it yes i think you can okay
you're going to get your first look at
the daviri paradoxes finally finally i
know i know it's been a couple of years
but duver paradox is going to be what
tennolive is all about and i'm so happy
the team worked really hard on the
teaser you're about to see for it and
i'm just really proud and excited to
show it awesome well thanks so much for
being here on summer game fest let's
take a look at that right now
[Music]
my child
my friend
what was done is done
new dangers
new choices await us now
for now
dream of who we were
[Music]
and of who we have become
next it's time for a new look at hong
kai star rail an upcoming open world
space rpg yeah a lot of space today from
gentian impact studio hoya verse across
mobile and pc this studio continues to
deliver and this new trailer reveals for
the very first time a new and exotic
realm players will be able to explore
[Music]
listen
you are in a daze right now
you don't know who you are
why you're here
none of that matters
in the near future
you will encounter many perils
you will meet companions who treat you
like family
and embark on unimaginable adventures
[Music]
remember what you feel in this moment
as long as you know in your heart where
you're heading
you will arrive at the end of the story
that's the you i like
[Music]
i have wine to soothe the souls of
honored guests
welcome aboard the ciao
and that's not all from hoyoverse today
i'm excited to introduce you to zenless
zone zero their next major new ip it's a
futuristic urban action game i have to
say i'm blown away by what i've seen so
far it was announced a couple weeks ago
and it has the detail of gentian impact
with a fast-paced action style here is
the world premiere of a brand new look
at zenless's notable characters armed
enemies and world of danger
[Music]
so
can you
hide
all right
one of my favorite reveals last year was
tmnt shredders revenge which reminds us
all of the turtles arcade games back in
the day well it's nearing the end of
development and the team wanted to use
sgf as a way to reveal one exciting
aspect of the game they've been keeping
under wraps until now
[Music]
patrick
[Applause]
[Music]
party
oh
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
right
[Music]
how far will you push humankind
humankind allows you to shape your
civilization by combining a multitude of
historical civilizations from the
ancient to the modern era
one piece is celebrating its 25th
anniversary this year and bandai namco
is bringing the mega popular franchise
back to video games with one piece
odyssey monkey to luffy and his crew of
pirates are off on their next adventure
this trailer reveals the setting a
mysterious island where luffy and his
straw hat crew
become marooned in this exciting
upcoming jrpg
the straw hat pirates journeying along
the grand line
miro
foreign
see
[Music]
sorry
filled with new encounters
[Music]
and hidden mysteries
unravel the adventure that awaits
in an odyssey beyond imagination
one-piece odyssey
this august soul hackers 2 from atlas
launches and we've got your first listen
to the english voice cast with this
quick new look
[Music]
ringo
take my hand
[Music]
you'll get one more chance to make
things right
so that's our mission then save the
world
[Music]
with so many new games featured across
sgf events you might be wondering how to
plan for your summer gaming dreams nerd
wallet can help you find the smartest
credit card to reward your gaming
purchases at nerdwallet.com
the epic mega sale is going on right now
save up to 75 off top pc titles with an
additional 25 off eligible products and
it wouldn't be the mega sale without the
free games vault featuring man eater be
sure to claim your copy before the sale
ends on june 16th
tune in to the epic game store twitch
channel for our summer showcase on june
10th at 2pm eastern 11 am pacific we're
taking a look at new announcements and
updates from pc titles heading to the
store this year and beyond
[Applause]
[Music]
you nuts
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
three
[Music]
you're gonna get hit with the unexpected
in mario striker's battle league in this
no holds bark soccer-ish sport chaos
reigns supreme so prepare to do whatever
it takes to claim victory so much fun it
hurts mario striker's battle league only
on nintendo switch game rated everyone
10 and up
[Music]
hi my name is carl and i'm a developer
and metal hell singer you know how in
some games with the music is really good
you feel compelled to move and shoot to
the beat but what if you had to in metal
the better you are at slaying to the
beat the more intense everything gets
and we have vocal performances from
legendary artists like serge thank you
from system of a down so while head
banging isn't mandatory we do recommend
it our demo is live now on steam xbox
and playstation platforms so go check it
out and slay to the beat
[Applause]
foreign
oh
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Laughter]
that one was metal hellsinger coming
later this year from fun com a rhythm
shooter with metal music and right now
as i mentioned a demo has launched on pc
xbox and playstation for you to play for
free
next up a new game launches tomorrow the
quarry from super massive games this
spiritual successor to until dawn stars
david arquette and an all-star cast
that's getting great reviews and this is
one of those binge-worthy teen horror
entertainment experiences where your
every choice shapes your story and
determines who lives and who dies at a
camp in upstate new york here's the
first look at the launch trailer
family is the most important thing in
the world
[Music]
but if your whole family
you know like
every last one of them decided to jump
down the bottom of a well they're all
just
hanging on the end of a rope how can one
person be expected to pull them all back
out you can't
[Music]
so you pull on that rope and you're just
gonna fall right down at the bottom of
the well with the rest of them
[Music]
and what's the point of that
what
there is a lot more to this than you
realize
like what
kidnapping murder cover-ups i think the
whole hackett family is in on it
you have no idea what's going on here
not a goddamn clue
[Music]
all right let's do this
who should i call 911. you mean 9-1-1
who says 91-1
good-bye cool world
we gotta get out
i'm gonna enjoy watching you die
this isn't a ghost story it's a creature
feature it's really happening and you're
all in it this is gonna get a little
messy
[Music]
them's the rules you noob
back at the game awards we were proud to
reveal nightingale a shared world
survival crafting game from inflection
games up in canada now it's time to give
you a brand new look and deeper look at
the game including its innovative realm
card system that lets you impact things
like the weather pattern resources and
challenges in its procedural realms here
is your exclusive new look
[Music]
you're alone in the realms i'm afraid
the portals are a
mess
not even sure if nightingale made it
given how fragile you humans are
i'd say that staying fed dry and rested
should be your priority
if the portal arch is inactive you'll
need to make round cards from rare
resources
once you have round cards you can
activate the portal
beware though
foul things lurk in the interim void
waiting to get in
be ready with your axe pick
[Music]
if these shadows have offended
think but this
and all is mended
[Music]
the saints are marching in on august
23rd with the reboot of saints row that
we revealed last year at gamescom and
today we're happy to announce the launch
of the boss factory demo across pc and
console which lets you design and set up
your character and since it's saints row
you guys are gonna have a lot of fun
with this one check it out
[Music]
guys
you gotta do something to capture
people's attention so what do we build
next
[Music]
dinner and a show baby
quicker
i want all the power
[Music]
all the power
next we've got an exclusive first look
at extended gameplay of warhammer 40k
dark tide fat sharks follow up to the
critically acclaimed vermintide series
dark tide promises intense four-player
co-op action and terrifying enemy hordes
to team up against and it's our out on
september 13th for pc on steam and
exclusively on console on xbox
[Music]
manufacturer
1736 is heading towards your power
systems failure thanks to a bit of
heretic sabotage
so you're gonna restore the colon and
hopefully save the day
again
access the operations array and use the
cryonic rods to flush the system
preferably before something explodes
head on through the ventilation tunnels
and look for an access point
this way move it
[Applause]
[Music]
set your data interrogators if all goes
well we can unlock the system prime the
rods
that's the first part done
get to the base of the matrix fire and
put those cryonic rods to work
look for a way out
[Music]
bluebird team is known for psychological
horror games like blair witch and the
medium today they are ready to reveal
their latest creation made completely in
unreal engine 5 for a visceral horror
experience it's a return to the world of
layers of fears get a dose
of this
[Music]
someone once said insanity runs in our
family
let it
run
[Music]
so
they say it's a tale of sadness and
guilt of an artist trapped in a place
beyond redemption
this is a story of my fear being an
hatred of the horror of my loneliness
and it is mine
to tell
[Music]
now i see it
all this misery
all this suffering there was no other
way
[Music]
you really
shouldn't
have
[Music]
an empty shell
cannot live forever
[Music]
i was trapped in this house bound by
this body
now
i break free
[Music]
this october gotham nights arrives
batman is dead and it's up to the batman
family batgirl nightwing red hood and
robin to protect gotham to give us an
exclusive new look let's head to
montreal to hear from executive producer
fleur marty
hello and warm welcome from wb games
montreal i'm fla marti i'm the executive
producer on gotham nights
today we are thrilled to share more with
you on one of our beloved nights
nightwing
this showcase is the first in our
character series and we're really
looking forward to share more with you
as we continue working towards our
launch on october 25th
so i hope you enjoyed the show and stay
tuned
i had nothing
and then this city became my home
its people became my family
got gotham gave me everything
it deserves to feel safe
[Music]
no matter how hard we try
there's always more to do
and now
it's up to me
i got this bruce
that was gotham knights and now we
welcome oh look who it is neil druckmann
from naughty dog co-president of naughty
dog uh great to have you with us neil
it's been a uh an eventful day on the
internet for naughty dog fans and uh i
think we jinxed ourselves we were joking
about last night like watch the assets
will leak and yes lo and behold
well the good news is there's some stuff
that hasn't leaked that we have lots to
share with people about all things at
naughty dog but first of all it is a you
know it's a big month actually for last
of us fans because uh last of us one and
two both launched in june and it's
nearing its two-year anniversary for
last of us uh part two which is hard to
hard to believe
yeah it's crazy uh um you know nine
years for last of us one two years for
less was part two and we still hear from
fans they're still sending us letters
and art and these characters in this
journey in this world mean so much to
them
um
and it's it's just been kind of amazing
like last was part two early this year
passed a pretty big milestone it sold
over 10 million units and that kind of
support that kind of success um we're so
grateful to our fans it has allowed us
to grow as a studio and now we can take
on multiple projects more than we've
ever had at the same time
multiple projects okay very interesting
so uh what can last us last of us fans
expect in the future from you thank you
for asking jeff
uh so one of the things we've mentioned
a while back is what started out as a
multiplayer mode has evolved due to the
team's ambition they really wanted to do
something beyond what we've ever done
before at naughty dog and we felt the
way to do it justice is to make it a
standalone title and over the they've
been working on it for the past two
years ambition has grown and we're not
quite ready to fully unveil it but we're
ready to lift the current a little bit
and just give you like an update of
where we're at
okay well uh what can you tell us about
this new standalone multiplayer game
yeah so uh we have a concept art that we
want to show um
uh but what i can tell you oh
is that this game is big okay um it's as
big as any of our single-player games
that we've done and in some ways bigger
it's got a story um the way we're
telling that story is very unique to
this game
it's got a brand new cast of characters
it takes place at another place another
part of the united states it's like a
city might somewhat familiar some people
i'm sure our fans have already figured
it out um
uh and it's it's really cool and it's
being headed by vinith agarwal um
anthony newman and joe padnaty all
veterans of uncharted and last of us and
you're going to see a lot more of this
game come next year
next year so i wait till next year to
hear more about that one okay well very
exciting that this has evolved and i
mean that concept art looks incredible i
can't wait to see naughty dog
storytelling fused with multiplayer live
game uh it's it's something special we
can't wait to show it either okay well
um that's not all we also have something
that i've been reading about on the
internet every day it feels like up in
calgary they're filming the last of us
show for hbo right
yeah so uh for the past year um you know
we've teamed up with craig mason of
chernobyl fame and hbo to adapt the last
of us into a tv a tv show um they've
been filming and uh
it's pretty incredible the stuff i'm
getting back when we're looking at back
at naughty dog we can't help but feel
emotional because not only is it so good
and the quality is so high it's so
authentic to what we've made in the game
um and
uh i i just can't i couldn't be proud of
like again craig and that whole crew and
everybody that's up there uh and they're
actually their last day of filming is
tomorrow so the entire series last day
of filming
filming is tomorrow craig is up there
right now kind of wrapping it all up uh
so it's it's pretty close it's closer
than you might think and you actually
got to direct one of the episodes
yes uh i think that really speaks to the
kind of collaboration and trust that
exists between naughty dog and hbo they
invited me to direct one of the episodes
um i think we have an image from the
episode actually directed oh okay we
could first look let's take
so you can see uh this is a certain
museum that players might know from the
game um and i really have to talk about
pedro pascal and bella ramsey and not
only directing them but seeing them do
all the other episodes they've thrown
themselves at these roles for a whole
year
watching the nuance that they bring to
these characters their relationship on
and off camera i couldn't help but think
about troy baker and ashley johnson it
felt so similar to the chemistry those
two actors had when we made the game um
and it really feels like this is going
to be something special and i will say
this will be the most authentic video
game adaptation yet well i mean that
first image that they put out it just i
mean it feels like the video game
everything that i've seen both public
and other stuff makes it feel sort of
super legitimate you said and that's
awesome to see uh joel and ellie from
from the front side now for the first
time um so we'll see more of that at
next year that's coming as well right
serious uh you'll hear about it very
soon that's okay i'll say right now all
right well last of us hbo very very
exciting uh and i hear you actually have
a couple actors from the show who are uh
gonna join us we happen to have a couple
actors here that are part of the show we
should bring them up okay come on up
[Music]
oh what's up guys hello surprise troye's
back again hello hello
good to see you uh i'm a little confused
though i thought maybe pedro bella but
troy ashley out here uh ex from the game
right so uh when craig and i started
working on the show almost one of our
very first meetings we said troy and
ashley have to be a part of it um and
we're such fans of like the talent and
the help like helping us create joel and
ellie um we felt like it was so
important that they become part of the
show and it wasn't
it has to be more than just like kind of
like a wink to the camera and like a
cameo yeah these are real roles that
we're keeping on the wraps for now
uh-huh uh but man i was i'm bummed that
i couldn't be there with you guys when
you filmed your stuff there's been so
much stuff so
so good on the internet there's so much
like talk about what's being filmed and
i think that's you guys have kept a
complete secret that you so you were up
there and you filmed your roles by now
obviously well keeping secrets with this
franchise is kind of old hat like we've
had for today
except for the date
uh it was it was one of the hardest
things for us to do is to let not let
people know that because we're so proud
of it and the work that we did we worked
hard the crew i have to say um when i
walked out on set
um
to be met with literally every person
that i met on that crew
uh is such a fan of this game and they
all knew what it was that they were
working on and committed to working on
this project because of their fan and
their love for the for the game uh was
one of the greatest it was like i was
coming home
to friends
yeah i i the attention to detail
the crew was amazing bella and pedro are
man
i
they're so perfect and it it we've been
trying to sort of describe that feeling
of sort of seeing them in person
it's it's like
it's like the characters coming to life
but it
it's so much more than that i feel like
i can't fully explain it but i am
so excited to be a part of it and
just
i can't wait to see it i think it is
going to be
so good
it's it's i love the story i love
just being a part of i'm so excited
about the series and the fact that you
guys are gonna be in it and undisclosed
roles i'm so fascinated how it's gonna
sort of
bob and weaving and you know are these
characters we know from the game that
they're playing new characters can you
tell us anything
yes
[Laughter]
i can tell you so sneaky all right well
we're so excited maybe it's already on
twitter
hey all right well
let's talk about what was on twitter
earlier uh today lots of talk about uh
the idea or really what's happening is
it looks like you guys are remaking the
original game and this is like a
ground-up remake is that right that's
right uh we wanted to give people the
definitive version of the the first game
that wasn't encumbered by any technology
uh wanted to find a way to get even
closer to our original vision
and we're able to do it on the ps5
and pc and instead of talking about it
let's look at it all right let's take a
look at the last of us part one
so why'd you leave boston
i've been on quite the adventure little
brother
i reckon it's got something to do with
that girl
he's got everything to do with that
little girl
[Music]
you know
i've never been this close
to the outside so is that everything you
hoped for
can't be any worse out there
can it
once upon a time
i had somebody that i cared about
and in this world that's good for one
thing
get you killed
i can take care of myself how many close
calls have we had
i get in trouble down there you make
every shot
count
i got this
hope you know how to use that thing
i've had some practice
truly one of my favorite games of the
past decade guys what's your reaction to
that yeah we haven't seen that yet yeah
you're watching it in real time yeah
uh
it's because you did these before i mean
these performances you did a decade ago
yeah you didn't go back in i mean you
used the original performances yeah
actually we came up with a process where
we could take the original
uh animation that we did for the faces
and kind of like retarget it on these
new rigs that have a lot more fidelity
and then the animators went back and
forth side by sides here just how much
it has changed that you went and you
redid the models and rebuilt everything
everything was rebuilt from the ground
up uh same art director re-art directed
the whole thing from the ground up um
but the the great thing about these
faces is that um they're closer to their
original performance all the animators
went and studied those videos and got it
closer to what you did on set than we
could have achieved before um and that's
just like one of the things and we could
talk about like this brand new ai like
all the combat is redone um
just uh the fidelity of everything 60
frames per second all the stuff you're
getting on the ps5 again we wanted to
give knowing because of the show because
this they're all all new players for ps5
and pc we wanted them to have the
definitive version of the last of us
amazing well now you guys get to reply i
mean when was the last time you guys
played the game
i i actually played it again just to
refresh my memory before working on the
show
um
i was a just a glutton for punishment
and i went straight from playing uh
never playing straight into part two
um and so the last time i played
literally would have been two years ago
since we're celebrating the anniversary
of part two coming out so i mean it
looks like i'm definitely going to be up
for another year
yeah i can't wait to go back because i
can't you guys do such an amazing job on
that original game and it's really when
you play it when you see it in motion
it's really night and day from what it
used to be imagine that you know the
think of the last of us to combat but
kind of that back in the last of us once
it's the whole like all the new
animation system the new ai system
everything we've learned on like
untreaded four last of us two we applied
to this again to give that definitive
version just to give a quick shout out
uh this project is headed up by matthew
gallant and shawna skye
and you'll hear a lot more about it and
see a lot more about over the coming
weeks leading up to the release
september 2nd on ps5
all right and shortly thereafter on pc
we will look forward tonight neil you've
talked a lot about games directed by
other people what what are you directing
you still making games still making
games uh i haven't given up my day job
uh
it's a little early to talk about it
maybe if someone in places wants to leak
it then we can talk about it now uh
otherwise uh we'll say but you do have a
new project do have a new project but
we'll save it for another summer game
fest okay
okay well we'll see we'll try and save
it all right troy ashley neal thank you
so much for dropping by summer game fest
and i am so excited that the last of us
is returning as you said in september so
thanks guys appreciate it thanks jeff
awesome
all right well that is gonna do it
thanks to naughty dog and playstation
for that very special uh look at the
last of us and the entire franchise and
where things are going um very very
excited about that all right summer game
fest continues over the next few days
coming up right now on this dairy stream
is day of the des with im8 bit and
double fine including an exclusive new
look at the planet atlanta and then the
devolver digital showcase tomorrow we've
got netflix geeked week which i'll be
co-hosting and the tribeca game showcase
streaming along with the epic games
store showcase and then finally sunday
it's the xbox and bethesda game showcase
you can stream them all at
summergamefest.com
as for me i'll see you again in august
when we are back live in cologne germany
for gamescom opening night live on
august 23rd and then the game awards
will return in december live from the
microsoft theater in los angeles and
finally i'm excited to share that summer
game fest will return in june 2023 as a
digital and in-person event to bring the
gaming community together thanks for
being a part of summer game fast and
remember there are more events and
announcements to come we'll see you soon